he is enter his 15th season Wow in the
National Football League the former
Super Bowl MVP I guess once a Super Bowl
MVP MVP always won also a league MVP he
is none other than Aaron Rodgers how are
you Aaron
hey buddy thanks for having me back
finally no come anytime anytime Aaron
very rarely do I start the interview
this way but how's the mustache going
right now where are we right now on this
front it's gone come on no what what
yeah yeah shave it off last night Aaron
Rodgers cuz we were gonna suggest you
know since you've done you've done the
Sam Elliot and then you've done the the
whole happy gilmore thing we were gonna
suggest you go through the Wilford
Brimley IMDB page with that thing you
could have you could have dyed it and
really worked it it's gone talking about
diabetes it's the right thing to do
correct yes that's what we could have
done it's going preaching for next time
I'll keep that in mind well what
happened what why just what happened
they were just getting in the way too
much you know too much hidden in the
mustache you know I'm trying to move on
to look clear the decks in time for the
season pretty much is what you're saying
a lot of guys yeah a lot of guys were
actually given me some crap about it I
mean 50 50 compliments to crap but that
move on well if there's anything
anything to smoke out Sam Elliott for me
is would I give the blue checkmark to it
did you ever hear from him did you get
any call after the Canadian tuxedo from
him now still waiting on that but I'm
holding out hope for sure one day one
day Aaron Rodgers here on the Rich Eisen
show okay Aaron I have no idea what your
offense is gonna look like can you give
me any hint any idea what's going on at
all nah check us out Thursday you clear
you see it in you know the first
opportunity okay it's been good you know
Frank's been good well we had a lot of
stuff in
you know but this is kind of way of many
teams I think most in general played
there they're guys you know maybe a
little bit a third and that's about it
and that's kind of the way things went
the entire preseason so you know I think
our first team - myself played about 15
snaps ish right but you know got a lot
of your practice time and and I know
people it's not like the game well I
would contend that you know the practice
reps against defenses actually run on
their stuff is is more is better
preparation than you know a preseason
game where they're not where they run on
their stuff you know it's simple stuff
most time in preseason two or three
coverages two or three fronts and I feel
good about the preparation we got in
this camp okay so - Packer fans that
have been howling at the gates for
innovation will they get it or were they
off to begin with Aaron well I think
they're probably off to begin with you
know we had an offense that was one of
the top two or three copycatted offense
four years in the league and that's kind
of the way it goes
you know when a team gets hot on offense
people start you know trying to copy
their plays and fit it in their own
schemes and you saw that with our
offense for a long time you've seen that
knowing them for a long time you know
when Chip Kelly first got in the league
you saw a lot of teams trying to do what
they were doing there and you know
what's going on with Andy and them in
Kansas City and then obviously this
offense with the you know cow Shane has
been running and Shaun McVeigh and and
Matt you know here you know it's it's
kind of one of the newer trends and
League but you know we've been on the
forefront of of those trends and this is
just a different different type of
offense you know more you know cut
splits and you know actions you know
tying up directly with the runs and you
know still a lot of stuff additional
scrimmage and a lot of adjustments
whether they're out adjustments or run
pass adjustments or run run adjustments
or pass pass adjustments
that you know I think challenging
mentally but you know definitely this
offense puts stresses on on defensive
fits and I discipline and that's why
you've seen you know what I was done and
in San Fran you know and that's we saw
it firsthand last year what obviously
was Shawna's has done thickens teens
throughout last year and this offense is
you know kind of a hot offense I know
Aaron Rodgers here in the Rich Eisen
show and if he sounds more clear than he
has in the last couple weeks it's
because there's no mustache in front of
his mouth anymore right here on the Rich
Eisen show see I just reset your
identity by talking about you without
you being in the first person right
there I think you probably picked up on
that right there I did thank you yes I
got a lot of fun comments this morning
and workout man you look a lot younger
you know I might have to do that this is
my last move this beard and this
mustache that I've got going on here
Aaron you know I'm I'm towards the end
if you will I'm out of options
I'm out I'm out you know I'm pretty much
out of options
in the few minutes I have left with you
here what did you I know you mentioned
about luck and how it was the reaction
of the fan base in Indianapolis was a
little disgusting as the words that you
used can you put into words as somebody
who clearly battles injuries as much as
you do we saw it last year in particular
what does go through the mental aspect
of this that you might have related to
with Andrew Luck Aaron well I think it's
the the Groundhog Day effect that it has
on your mind when you're so focused is
rehab and a lot of rehab is you know
repetitive and if you don't see any
types of jumps during in recovery you
know say it's in a week or two weeks or
you know for a major injury a month you
know definitely messes with your mind a
lot and then I think kids a natural to
start thinking about your post career
health and whether it's you know with
concussions or surgeries
you know whatever extremity it might be
that comes into play on your ability to
live a functioning physical life after
football and I think watching some guys
go through a couple years of you know a
year year and a Bree had kind of like
Andrew did Jordy Nelson I mean went
through basically an ACL reconstruction
to another leg injury and it was about a
year and a half for him a Brianne just
get back on the field for the following
season
and it messes with your head for sure
and it you know stuff days of rehab and
I think it's only natural to think about
man is this my best quality of life or
do I still have the passion or you know
is it time to to do something else and
and then get happy again and that's why
I applaud him for making a decision I
think it's actually the selfless
decision instead of hanging around and
making he figures he's choosing to you
know to to improve his life and try
something else do you have an end game
envisionment scenario already played out
in your head for you yeah when the Super
Bowl when I'm 45 and right off and I
said did you do you envision yourself
playing deep into your 40s if you can
what's the imminent and vision playing
as long as my body feels good and I have
you know the love for the game that that
I do right now you know that you know
still fuels me and still a passion and I
still love the daily grind and the
practice and the preparation and if I
can give everything to team in that
manner then and my body feels good I'm
gonna keep rolling and I'm already
hearing the the what I don't want to
hear to be honest with you Aaron Aaron
Rodgers here and the Rich Eisen show is
that is that Lux a deep thinker
he's an over-thinker you know he's a
smart guy and that smart guys when they
realized that they are playing this game
that might be a red flag to draft more
smart guys so I
kakaw bear is that is that a fair
assessment I don't think it is but I
just want to know from somebody who does
play the game and obviously deal with
injuries and has a brain that that do
you think that's a fair view you know I
think it's probably a ridiculous view by
folks who don't have any creativity or
any other interests outside of the thing
right in front of them 24/7 and I think
the beauty in this game is meeting you
know teammates who have interests
outside of football you know guys who
are either skilled business-wise you
know we had teammate Ricky jean-françois
who's got a number of you know chain
restaurants that he's you know he story
became a franchise owner and and she's
got kind of a second career plan already
set up you know you meet guys who are
incredible musicians or you know really
you know interested in you know travel
or charitable work or whatnot you know I
think having interest is what allows you
to to have that balance off the field
which I think makes your on the field or
at the stadium or in the facility work
that much more important the ability to
compartmentalize the off the field stuff
and love that and have a passion for
that but realize that have this place
but when I'm at work when I'm on the
field that's my sole focus and I think
you can't have enough of those type of
guys who are well-rounded people and
have you know a creativity in a
curiosity about more than just ball
because I think that those guys get
burnt out and those guys are not as
relatable and when you're talking about
leaders you need to have fine guys who
can be relatable in a locker room and I
think people who only can ever talk
about football you know a hard time
relating to every person or the multiple
people in the locker room because guys
have interests and you have to find ways
to relate to them in the locker room to
get them to buy and then what are you
trying to do in the last couple minutes
a half with you Aaron
Rogers it's another endeavor I haven't
spoken to you since then the Game of
Thrones appearance by you so many people
think they thought they saw you can you
give some clarity where you were in this
this cameo that you had in the finale of
Game of Thrones of the final season yeah
I was in the tunnel
with Arya as she after she left the
hound and tried to make her way out of
the city hmm
you know it's one of those things where
it's not exactly like they focused on me
for five or six seconds it's kind of a
quick quick glimpse okay but it was fun
to do in Belfast you know I think I've
made my comments known about how yes I
wasn't a huge fan of brand being you
know the Game of Thrones winner right
but but now I love my experience in
Belfast and I love the show and
hopefully there'll be some sort of
spin-off little captivate us for the
next
I agree over any years so you were did
did you get incinerated they did that's
what happened to your character or we no
no no no okay that wasn't me you see
that person running tell me about it I'm
being part of Darren Revell running on
Twitter right now Aaron that's an
outrage I can't have it anymore I think
your forms gotten better over the years
I appreciate that I appreciate that
hey Aaron I always enjoy our chats you
take care of yourself and look for my
call during the season
I'll keep reaching out you got it that's
Aaron Rodgers that Aaron Rodgers 12 for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app